bioinformatics for precision medicine
hello everyone my name is mohit mazumdar
and i'm one of the
co-project mentor of the program so
as uh as for today let us go through the
through the sessions that we are going
to have uh what actually
they are discussed and what we have in
the curriculum
how that aligns with uh the subject and
the importance of what we discussed
today
so let me let us go through the sessions
um
as uh one by one
one second
yeah so the first uh first session of
the program
will be on 6 july and it will start with
an overview of all the resources that
your uh
all the resources that we discussed and
also the access to the program
so for the first session this will
include program orientation
group discussion uh to learn from the
participants of the program and about
the
about the research interests and
objectives so the orientation
is also is to get you familiarized with
uh the introduction to bioinformatics
so followed by this uh the first session
which is a
scheduled session to which focuses on
the problem
of cancer so in this session we will
also discuss about the complexity of
cancer biology
and the typical challenges that you see
in diagnostics at the
organ tissue or cellular level and we
will also discuss about molecular
factors that
that are involved in um in tumor
development
that are there in uh in for basic and
both the basic and both
translational research in oncology so
in this study uh where we have also a
few examples like ilia said to all of
you that we have already prepared a few
examples so in in one of the examples
is a study where you can see on the
screen uh a patient-derived cell line
and
this uh in this xeno the xenograft
models are also used in another study
and we have also uh info i mean
data sets where we use clinical trials
uh information
that offers a collection of data to
understand and
get information about the diagnostics
and also
treatment of cancer in patients
so uh the next session after that which
would be the second session
in the second session we will talk about
the technology after getting an overview
of
cancer and how deadly it is and what are
the different
characteristics to understand a cancer
cell so in the second session it will be
more about the technology as i'm saying
uh so it would be about understanding
how next generation sequencing works you
will run about shotgun sequencing reads
and then you'll learn about how to make
the data structured and then
you will learn about different
bioinformatics methods
that uses uh like processing
where we will be doing both germline and
somatic mutations
we'll look at the analysis where we will
do mapping
detection uh variants you can see on the
screen and also
in this in this uh in the last part
so in the last part of the session we
will discuss about the interpretation so
how can you interpret this data
and along with this like you will have
access to the resources that explains
all of this so that you kind of get
familiarized with what is being covered
and have a chance to do it at your at uh
at your own pace
so anytime that you feel that you have
uh
you have time to go through the
resources these are online courses that
are available on the
learn omix logic portal so in here i
mean we have different resources that it
starts from a very intro very basic
introduction and then
goes into different processing pipelines
and how data can be interpreted
and how you can uh structure that data
that could make sense because it's from
a large large number of uh you know it's
a big data
and then you're transforming into a very
meaningful data set
so in this in this study in this session
i mean we will learn about how genomics
is used
in biomedical drug discovery and how
genomics is used
in different other areas
in translational research so in the
third session
which will be on processing of
another type of sequencing data which is
uh the transcriptomics
data so in this uh session after
learning about the genomic processing
data and its application in biomedical
research
and precision medicine you will learn
how we can measure
uh functional proteins and
look at the mrna abundance and
understand accurately understand the
alternative splicing so
you saw examples of rna sequencing
before so going through this entire
process of rna sequencing doing the read
quality and pre-processing
yourself going and then mapping it to
the reference genome
and then understanding its role uh by
quantifying the genes and also the
transcripts
and in the same way after doing that you
would want to do the visual
visualization so um i think um
this entire process is also to let the
scientific community know of what you
have under
what you have obtained from as a result
so
expressing that in a visual form and
getting the visualization is a
scientific is a very important part of
our scientific
uh scientific things that we do uh every
day
so in that sense we will learn about how
you can correctly and uh
visualize uh the gene expression
uh information and also do pca uh to do
that and also go
go through annotation and interpretation
so
in this uh in this session uh we will be
going through the
the for example the processing pipelines
we will prepare a full
pipeline and then go through different
type of analysis that we
do for uh gene expression uh data
so the session after that uh which will
be the fourth session
uh is on machine learning so you have
already learned about two
overview of two uh different um
different technologies which is genomics
and transcriptomics and then
you would want to learn about how do you
you know do this
makes make sense of this data and do
this uh
to find out uh different patterns that
are lying within
a large number of other data sets also
so finding predictive modeling
or like understanding how this data
what this data have information
so this uh complex collection where this
is
about the data in the complex collection
we are looking at
different types of characteristics we
are looking between
correlation between a clinical
manifestation of disease
molecular patterns and how we can define
it
uh using different statistical analysis
right so machine learning approach
allows computational
uh power that could be applied to these
challenges so in this session
uh we will use machine learning and
during this uh
during this time as i was saying that
there will be resources
allocated that will help you go through
and do this uh
on your own so you will also have access
to the coding platform uh
coding uh playground which is there in
learn
where you can write and you know do
scripting in python and r and these also
ex
they are also like tutorials that takes
you through this entire process
so you know you know how to um apply r
and python
in your genomic or transcriptomics data
analysis
so uh yeah that would be an experience
and that
uh these those will be uh available
uh to you as uh the session goes on and
we will
cover many of those aspects in these
live sessions so after going through and
learning about how do you visualize and
how can you
actually analyze uh from different
project examples that we have prepared
for you
the next thing is to go and do it
yourself like finding those
important repositories on and finding
the um data sets from those important
repositories like uh
sra jio ncbi in that that are there in
ncbi and you already already discussed
about
the tcga repository so this session will
be about those
different repositories that are there
and very important for
any bioinformatician to you know explore
and
understand how to extract uh the
information that you need
for your project so we will be
discussing in that respect
and about the i mean opportunity many of
us here do not even understand the
opportunity that is
related to training like this i mean why
we are doing this
why uh why we are saying that our
independent
research is now very much possible and
within
reach of everyone why why so it's it's
because
uh the availability of data and yes i
mean uh
that that kind of data is available so
uh and ncbi is such a good example of
that you can see that how many
data sets have been uh already deposited
and on the way it is growing rapidly
every day
so after learning about the data sets
and how to figure out and find data
we will uh again after the first phase i
think it would be
it would be five sessions and then after
the fifth session the sixth session
would be about next generation
sequencing where we will learn about
viral genomes
in the host transcriptome so here we
will also learn about
oncolytic viruses so that is one of the
one of the feature of
learning through precision medicine
program is to learn about
uh different aspects of transmissions
uh from cancer and then these uh
different
viruses so here we will also learn about
like how
they are involved in tumor development
how do you connect from biology to
cancer and then um learn about
inflammation and tissue damage
here we will also learn about how can we
align annotate
and and do you know
mapping so we will learn about viral
genomes
uh and we will also learn about uh
alignment to databases of those uh you
know viral genomes
so after learning about that so the
second phase in the
where we are we are going to learn about
uh different aspects of
how can we interpret uh biological
uh data from for virology and infectious
diseases
so in the in this session on uh which is
uh session seventh
we will learn about multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny
so here we will learn about how can you
study uh
viral genomes for uh liver blood and
neural tissues and we will also learn to
prepare data and setting
setting up bioinformatics pipelines
where you will find uh
uh to do phylogenetic analysis and
multiple sequence alignment of these
genomes so i think um most of you are
familiar with
phylogenetic tree so phylogenetics uh
is a study phylogenetics in in the study
of phylogenetics you learn about the
lineages
between different different species and
how you can interpret uh that
so after that uh so which is the seventh
session
so this is spanned across uh two
sessions a week
so i i think it would be all right and
we'll be going through this
and you'll get enough time to complete
the assignments and also go through some
of the
some of the courses and materials and
datasets that we have prepared for you
so learning about that uh
then practicing so it's a very important
aspect of this program
is to do the hands-on hands-on tutorials
and do the hands-on
practice yourself to gain the most of it
and become an expert right so to do
that uh you have to be more comfortable
by in the on the
on the platform that you will have
access to during the
during the uh during the one month
program so
uh here we will learn about workflows
and pipelines in bioinformatics so we
have discussed already have seen
a lot of uh pipelines and workflows
there like uh
algorithms uh that are um that are
in that are put together in a logical
manner right
so and that uh in that way
we have a technology that helps us to
find out and you know detect those
challenges and
find out uh critical important important
information
to design our prop uh to design our
research correctly
so this is a very important role that
plays in bioinformatics and here we will
learn about you know detecting
and mapping those two databases and we
will also learn about
how you can understand about uh how
genomic uh how genomics and genomes
uh and the evolutionary time correlates
so this is uh something that we have uh
planned for this session
and here we will also like uh go through
uh
some of the processes in this this is
another one of the example
this is a birth death
example of evolutionary study
so here uh you will also there are like
parameters that we will cover
that are there to understand this sort
of algorithm and what are different
algorithms to do this
and how they can be applied for a
problem
so about the problem um so now the next
session
is about the problem from infection
to pandemic from a viral adaptation
so here we will have an example about
the corona virus pandemic and we will do
uh take out such uh sequences from ncbi
virus
and we will do comparative studies where
we will compare
these four sequences uh genomic
sequences uh
full sequences and find out like how
they can correlate and how
they make sense in you know activation
of immune response
uh and then cytokine storm which is
caused by valid replication
and also could relate to what is
happening
currently um everywhere
so as i said uh that uh you would be
able to do it uh alongside with us
so we will use uh the tbi info platform
and where we have
sections uh on on to do this uh which is
virus quasi species so we'll discuss
this and we'll tell you like how
this is done um in session nine
so in after session 9 the last session
where this entire uh story comes to
an conclusion where we are going to
learn about host pathogen interaction
so after applying and learning about all
of these
technologies and how they can be done
for different diseases sorry
here we are going to learn about what
are the strategies that we can apply to
you know overcome so we will talk about
vaccine design so how bioinformatics are
how you can consider data and then think
about vaccine design so you have a lot
of information coming from big data you
know about the sequences
you know about the gene expression now
you have figured out that this is a
protein of my interest and
i think these are the possible sites and
uh based on the mutations that i've seen
in the genomics
these are some of the places that we
should target
and that these are some of the epitope
binding sites so
based on all that information uh the
important uh thing
is to go for uh a
data driven hypothesis and that
data-driven hypothesis
is something that we are going to uh
going to discuss throughout the program
so
uh in the session um we will cover about
uh some of the structure
such structures uh how do you connect
from
uh host response
to viral replica replication and then
implications of that to
a cell organ and tissue so exploring
different viral strategies for
exploitation of forced mechanism
machinery and the viral protein
production
so these are some of the topics uh and
sessions that
that are there for precision medicine
and i think one of the best part of this
is that we
also will be doing uh giving and going
through the courses
the coursework which actually uh is is
pretty amazing and that's what we have
heard from all of our
all of our participants so far so
after doing this and if you have any
confusion and if you think that
bioinformatics is difficult
because we are integrating so many
things we are integrating data
we are integrating algorithms we are
integrating complex machine learning
methods
it it sometimes gets like really thought
it thought it to be like sometimes it
gets really challenging
but we are here to help you out with
that because we have gone through this
entire process
over and over uh again and uh thought of
different strategies that actually uh
works
so